yeah okay we carry thee ship it
instantly I know patience is the key put
enough on my ship for free this is t we
carry feet Michael make your friend it
is t with garyvee and it is april 23rd
and i have high energy because I just
did gave a keynote to a small group of
12 executives in a global company and it
was really highly intellectual and I got
fired up Dustin I'm fired up this
morning I hope everybody else is I'm
coming in hot
that's good that's always good to hear
is it trying to compete with me that's a
good eight ball hat yeah my hair is
really annoying right now so I need it
we're ahead all right let's get into the
show everybody before we start the show
you're being selfish a lot of you are
not sure I looked so no [ __ ] now
just like I looked that none of you
[ __ ] have signed up for wine techs
and you're buying wine you're you know I
watch I literally gone to people that
have looked a team with Carey V put
their handle in Twitter then put in wine
found that you tweeted about wine two
years ago looked up your name in wine
text database and you haven't signed up
you [ __ ] [ __ ] so that's that but more
importantly I know that a lot of you
have not shared the show so please take
the URL right now and post it on Twitter
so my team team garyvee can retweet it
you can get some followers you can
amplify the show let's do that and let's
post it on Facebook as well cuz a lot of
you have huge audiences there and before
I go in let's absolutely say hello real
estate BJ always good to see you David
Centeno what's good my man new mess life
Amy and what's good Jessica Davis what's
good hackie raps tara lynn good to see
you who boxing nerd you're always in the
building I appreciate that Jose Leonardo
what's good always great to see you as
well leave comments I see Twitter
Facebook and YouTube comments in here
let's go learn to exercise thank you for
signing up today's wine is so crazy and
I'm gonna give the show $125 Pinot Noir
for 45 bucks I'm gonna say slowly the
wine sells for 125 bucks 45 bucks
like I'm going nuts like that's baller
you know yes sir it was a $10 wine today
is 45 bucks but if you're somebody who
drinks 12 and 13 $15 wine and it's
obviously co-ed so first of all motion
you shouldn't be buying wine if you
can't afford it but if you can and you
you drink wine if you drink $20 wine
leap up for a bottle or two of this
today because this is because you don't
drink hundred $25 wine if you buy $20
wine and you're not gonna get hundred
$25 wine for 45 bucks every day so big
day today for Pinot Noir lovers if
you're in for today's Pinot Noir please
say I'm in for today's Pinot Noir in the
comments just want to get a feel of how
pumped you are all right let's go into
it are you run bro I'm really good it's
good to see you Mike Boyd told me you
should trying to get you on this thing
yeah bro you look great you shaved the
beard you're looking great your hands
under there so my clothes over there I
see a bro it's great to see you
likewise how are you I'm good bro
everything's good you know I'm just
using this time to exercise and look
great music okay handsome bro Thanks
you're welcome you got a question but I
want to talk to you about oh four
Pistons everyone was talking about Bulls
these days I love it Mike now you got my
attention
Bulls these damn Detroit guy bro I'm
super you know I love the Knicks and but
I'm secretly a Pistons guy here's why
one they beat the [ __ ] out of Michael
Jordan before he was able to break
through those clothes lines and those
head butts and somebody who hated
Michael Jordan I just love what the bad
boys did to Mike they beat him up
everybody who all these youngsters who
don't know who like I'm just blinded by
listen Jordans the goat I get if I hate
them and like like kids don't even know
that Jordan couldn't get through them
kids don't even know that Jordan got
beat year after year after year by those
guys and then I hate Phil Jackson and
what what what the Oh for pit what the
Pistons did to the Lakers like the way
brown eyes what brown did to them what
brown did to Jackson that is a listen
when you have Jordan and Pippen and when
you have Shaq and Kobe I'd have seven
rings as a coach I love Phil and he's a
mastermind Zen and I'm like that he's a
Knick deep down so I love them but let's
not get it twisted
what brown did to him in that series we
could talk about fourth
it's all day clown no scary that could
have had Melo - I know if they didn't
take Darko I know I know all about it
like you got me fired up man I'm already
fired up this morning like yeah if they
had mellow it would have been that
would've been a four or five six-year
run and they in the next year they took
Spurs to seven the arm was repeated well
I'm super well I'm super aware Tony I'm
not an [ __ ] I just don't like Michael
Jordan cuz I'm a real Knicks fan and
real Knick fans who are in their forties
should not love him do I understand that
he's the greatest basketball player yeah
I think LeBron is if LeBron could sneak
one more in here and his all-around play
and kind of surrounding cast I think he
gets into a really great conversation
but how measly Brown that reads three
but he's been in nine finals he's three
and six in the finals which is what
everybody triggers him but like bro some
of those calves teams it was like LeBron
and like me you like like my Xander my
my seven year old and like I mean some
of those casts were not ridiculous for
LeBron did yes it Beca we knew before
they had Kyrie he was taken to the
finals a lot but Congress Weezy on teh
West unlike the guy with the hair and
like man anyway like I love you a lady
to keep pushing let's talk soon let me
keep going to show let's keep this going
sports oh how about this shirt the other
day I said to my team today's episode
was dirty and they sent me out this
dirty t-shirt I think we need to have to
put this up on Gary Vee shop Dustin I
think look I think this is a seller I
think you know I don't work people I
don't want people buying shirts right
now cuz the economy and everything but
like but I'm still salesman to and I
think that you know this is [ __ ]
fresh let's have a dirty T episode today
Dustin let's go
it's a dirty TT it's a dirty T let's go
oops - keep going hey how are you I'm
good how are you I'm well um so I wanted
to say thank you so much for this
opportunity and for quite frankly
changing my life
I suffered really bad anxiety
and listening to your podcast call me
down and motivated me more times than I
can count
um I listened to your talk on YPO for
the YPO group yesterday and my knife
yeah and my dad Britta said it was so
lovely a cabin you hear in Dubai and so
for my question I just turned 18 years
old and I've lost 100 pounds in three
years and I've documented it all on my
Instagram at Leon to journey which you
should follow by the way if you can't
get it wrong see new limited growth but
now I feel like I'm transforming and
creating a new identity for myself not
really related to weight loss I just
don't know what I want to become I know
I want to help others and make content
but I don't know what my niche is and I
know how important that is right
yeah sorry no I'm sorry but I'm just
gonna jump right in because I'm excited
and you got me fired up people think
they need to know what their Nisha is up
front instead of realizing they just
need to be a human and talk every day
and find it okay this is not about being
right this is about finding right okay
you're sitting and thinking all day of
like okay I've done this part of my life
I'm in a new place 15 to 18 was about
this and inspired certain people do that
but women you know now I'm in a
different place and that makes sense we
all have different laces but everybody
thinks they need to like sit and kind of
like come up with the right answer it's
not that what you need to do is put out
content every day yesterday your content
could have been or two days ago I just
listened to Gary on this why piano you
know Middle East thing it was cool one
thing he said was this or the next day
it's like I just you know these
raspberries and they were delicious and
the reason I eat raspberries this and
the next day is my sister said this the
next day is I saw this just be a human
obviously a human put that out everybody
worries about finding their niche being
right find anything that will make them
money and it doing well in likes and
followers that's the complete wrong
thing the right thing is when you don't
know is you go and make every day you
watch what happens then you realize that
people are liking this and you realize
you like cooking or you like exercise or
you like fruit or you like songs or you
like sports and then you make more of
that I didn't think six years ago oh I'm
gonna do parent
in content and that's gonna really help
no I had a random thought I put it out a
lot of reaction to it
from a boom you know like it's not super
complicated like you know the reality is
is that you don't know if you don't put
it out and you're really gonna be
crippled you know I'm telling you right
now I like the way I said that it's not
about being right up front it's about
creating a system that helps you find
right okay okay that sounds awesome okay
yeah so basically I was cutting I'm and
I love you I love your even your handle
thank you cuz a journey is everything
yeah like today you could be like okay
on my journey today I'm gonna try to
learn how to play chess
yeah that's actually so smart
and also you have to get serious about
tick-tock cause it's a place you can
explode okay I posted one tick-tock and
it kind of like blew up I mean for like
the region here I'm so like I should
have posted more I just have like a lot
cuz I talked about my anxiety and so I
should say like learn to like calm
myself down or not be insecure whichever
podcast on do me a favor watch this
video over and over for one minute like
bit like when it when it gets aired clip
it and just watch it and then post use
this moment to give you the courage to
post everyday what I'm saying but but
you're pissing me off
sorry because if you paid one [ __ ]
tick-tock and it blew up and then you
didn't do anything with it
that means it's here I we have to fix
this yeah cuz that's insane to me want
to inspire people you just did something
that worked and now what you're insecure
to post more like what you're
overthinking just making it just mere
crap right but I want you to do it okay
I'm gonna do it I'm gonna show you okay
good luck
I noticed a lot of times in the comments
people are trying to figure out how to
get on this show the way you get on the
show is you texting your number if
you're in the u.s. to this number or
Canada to this number two one two nine
three one five seven three one you ask
you a question put hashtag tea with Gary
be my team finds it you get a text
from us and you're crazy excited and we
get you in if you're international you
got to go to twitter twitter only if you
don't have one create one people like I
don't have a Twitter I'm like so you
don't get on the [ __ ] show dick like
create the Twitter and [ __ ] ask the
question asked a question hashtag tea
with Gary D that's how you get on the
show text or screen [ __ ] or tweet text
or tweet that's how you get on the show
let's keep it going hi hi how are you
I'm good umm so you know we're both
investors I run my fund and I know they
can do a little bit of investing too or
maybe a lot these days what do you do
right now to to help you know not just
your followers and fans here but the
people that you're investing in this is
this is crazy times right it sucks like
what what do we do what I've been doing
is one of two things either being their
kind of mental coach of like hey it's
not that bad you've never been through
this so just being a human being a
friend being an older brother a lot of
that and and a lot more actually of
fixing their businesses you know this
Sarah OH
all these Pete you know I've been
yelling about this for two years it's
why I stopped investing a lot you can't
build businesses that don't make money
and just rely on more venture
capitalists but I think a lot of people
thought that was gonna work forever I
was right that it wouldn't I mean I
remember 2008 it seems like there's a
there's a way unexpected or not of these
things crashing agree you know 10 20
years so it's the most it's the most
historically obvious thing a lot of time
what goes up must come down I mean and
so I've been spending a lot of time
trying to show them operationally how to
cut costs while I'm not going out of
business
yeah two things what I would call sweet
you know it's almost like how I do this
right it's either sweet love or it's
hardcore love okay super growth - isn't
it though because greatest people have
nothing to do except sit around and
watch us right now the greatest time for
growth this is this is this is a once in
a lifetime opportunity for people that
love offense yeah it feels like you have
to play defense because it feels like
you're drowning but the reality is if
you play off friends then you're gonna
be what's in your board to play offense
right a lot of these companies have to
be able to finance
or to play office yeah well yes I think
you have to get creative
right what work two months ago is is
done yep innovation is the only way out
of a pickle and this is a huge pickup it
is a sour sour pickle but some of us
love sour sour pickles were built for
navigating this time yeah how are you do
things well you know like you know I'm
comfortable in this environment because
this is all I know I don't do
entrepreneurship to buy a boat
I do entrepreneurship for when it's
going well and I do entrepreneurship for
when it's not going well I've also been
through 9/11 I've been through the 2000
Internet bubble I've been through the
2008 collapse like this isn't my first
rodeo I've got these grace you know so
you know um I'm cozy as a cucumber this
and I really know what the [ __ ] I'm
doing cucumbers and pickles that's what
it is tonight Sarah thanks for being on
thank you back let's keep this going
yeah real energy today Scottie stone Oh
what's up Gary it's all good bro how are
you I'm doing well
evil Frank oh hold on hold on mom I
don't know if you remember this name
this is gonna blow you I mean this might
be a little tough do you remember my
friend Abel who right before we moved he
was like a friend in my class who lived
in neighborhood remember I even went to
his house for Wrestlemania he's in the
chat yeah a bo Franco in the [ __ ]
building Abel Abel
I gotta connect with you bro I'm getting
back heavy into wrestling and every time
I think about wrestling I think about
Abel Franco and Abel's one of the few
people who know that I was the biggest
[ __ ] Macho Man Randy Savage fan and I
was at his house when Randy the Macho
Man Savage lost his title to Hogan and I
cried I basically cried and my mom
picked me up in a widow alright let's go
alright so so I've been in I got
involved while I was in the military and
in my career which is in security I got
involved in the training area I've been
doing training for like the last you
know 13 years but my passion is poker I
really enjoy poker so I wanted to
address it from a training standpoint
when I set up all my handles I realized
that I was like oh [ __ ] I
really don't know as much as I thought I
did so a friend yeah so I turned my
poker handle into the journey I turning
it into me wanting to be a professional
poker player and saying hey [ __ ] I don't
know as much as I thought I did so now
why don't you guys all join me
so my question and then my follow-up
question is when do or wench
when do I know that it's time to maybe
say all right after two years three
years four years that really maybe poker
isn't my thing and I should try
something different and on the backend
um have you ever been dismissed by
somebody that you looked up to in your
industry before you know you got here
and what I mean by that is is that of
course I follow I've been following you
for now almost a year started not giving
a [ __ ] when people think I started
posting a live I started posting you
know went to Google learned how to
stream learned how to set up my website
and I kind of set up you know YouTube
all that started DMing a bunch of poker
professionals poker amateurs poker
everything and I got some replies back
for some of one specific from a poker
professional who obviously I'm not going
to name but they kind of just blew me
off and told me that I should stop like
essentially like stop doing what you're
doing like you're not gonna make it like
it's you know and so from that
standpoint not caring what people think
but because he's already a professional
in the industry you know do I take that
to heart or do I just kind of be like
alright maybe you know so that's
essentially the question like what do
you think was gonna be that [ __ ] I
mean I know your answer is gonna be [ __ ]
them but because they're already been
there and they've already done it I mean
they enough some times okay they know
themselves they don't [ __ ] know what
is that your best [ __ ] friend are you
like me and six
[ __ ] them okay you know you looked up to
them until you knew who they were as a
human yeah exactly and then I figured
out I was like or maybe the tone of the
text was actually nice and maybe he was
saying it like hey bro don't do this
you're never gonna make it maybe it was
actually nice you know Tony's lost
behind text that's true that's true
maybe maybe I don't think so but maybe
that's what he's saying
for everybody who's watch
I definitely wouldn't value somebody's
opinion the bigger problem is you know
do you do you like the process or are
you trying to get there financially to
do something with those monies that
becomes the question becomes what are
you up to I love the process that's not
the problem I mean like I said it's it's
just the that kind of message that I
received back kind of just threw me off
and I was like oh [ __ ] your overvaluing
somebody else's opinion that knows you
4-0 just because they're good at the
thing yeah so as far as the first
question like where do I know that I
should be like maybe when you stop you
when you stop liking the process because
the way you're talking is not about the
process you're talking about getting
there and getting the financial benefits
which is ok I don't judge that Scotty I
just want to know that we're talking
real [ __ ] here yeah no of course and
that's the thing is like the process I
love the process and that's what I've
been documenting the entire time is
literally the process so why would there
ever be a stopping point once you're in
the process you're in forever ok yeah
you're right I know but I also don't
know if you're actually in it for the
dollar amounts which I would not judge I
mean that no and that's the thing is
like I want to use this platform when I
make money because I'm I'm the type that
wants to help out like I I wish I had
financial money right now to help out
with everything that's been going on I
mean I've been donating all my
tournament winnings to the all-in
challenge so like but it's not you know
it's like 20 dollars here 15 dollars
there like it's nothing big that I feel
like I'm making a difference with but
[Music]
ten dollars goes to ten dollars of
somebody eating that has zero when
you're like I don't have much but you're
like stuff in your room there's [ __ ]
people who have nothing and truly need
that ten dollars to eat right so you're
making a huge difference that I really
appreciate you of course thank you bike
for you buying my raffle tickets are you
buying somebody else yeah I love it you
win bro we're gonna be full year garage
saleing I'll [ __ ] show you to make
real money yes bro I think it comes down
to this are you actually in it for the
journey or are you in a place where deep
down subconsciously you're even
consciously you're like [ __ ]
can't wait to make a hundred thousand
five hundred thousand a year being a
great poker player if you're asking me
that part then I'm concerned because
that dude might have been right you you
know like you just might never be a
great poker player I'm doing it for a
journey is your hope to be good enough
that you can then sell people on how to
become that person if that's the
business model I'm not no no others me
I'm just honest I'm trying to figure out
what you're trying to do if you're in it
just for the journey
like I am by the way of course it's come
with financial success but right like
there is nothing else for me like you
know some people are like I can only be
a teacher I have to be a teacher and you
know unfortunately and if one cares
about finances for in that profession
you're not gonna be me and that's how I
am with entrepreneurship if this came
with a $40,000 a year thing there is no
other options all I ever did yeah
I don't know why evil Franco was a
shitty student cuz I remember he was I
was trying to sell baseball cards able
Franco you have a wonderful day
hey Abel do you remember do you remember
Abel when you and I saw each other with
who's a kid Friedman or what you know
when we saw each other in Hillsborough
in the Hillsborough Fire Station when I
did a sports card show like sophomore
year of high school and I hadn't seen
you since sixth grade and you went to it
abled you're still in here tell me if
you remember that [ __ ] that was that
made me happy cuz you guys got into
comic books too and like that's [ __ ]
misfire alright let's keep it going Gary
what's up dude what's up dude what's
your name damn dude Dan I love the sign
bro Dan you might be my favorite
all-time tee with Gary big ass bro I
love the billboard let's [ __ ] go hit
that up dude your dad's things are
amazing on Instagram right the hats
genius thank you he's gonna have a ton
of followers I agree
I got a breakdown some football draft
questions for you let's go big David
well that freaking Jerry Jones is
drafting his home by himself so that
scares me is that what's happening yes
label and just drafting by himself it's
gonna be crazy by the way I respect that
[ __ ] because I'm giving you the preview
I'm [ __ ] drafted by myself too when I
I'm going completely I'm like my 4gm she
or he is gonna have a tough job cuz I'm
[ __ ] I'm gonna be like I like this
kids mentality I don't give a [ __ ] how
fast you ran the 40 like I'm gonna be
I'm gonna be the worst owner
I might even play in a game I'm gonna be
in a 78 year old wide receiver I might
just do it I don't give a [ __ ] I listen
I worked my whole life for it so [ __ ] it
if I want to be you know I might die on
the field you know me for like win the
Super Bowl or something least something
right right what do you got bro so my
question is this is like a huge
difference with this technology so how
these guys gonna change it up so like
the guys like you know Tony Romo we're
at these small schools are kind of gonna
slide down the board a lot so your thing
last night with up B Parker and you know
he was hitting a lot of spots and it's
gonna be huge but you know which teams
you think you're gonna have an advantage
this year the teams that have the best
Scouts you know and I have a really
inappropriate since I'm really genuinely
now in the business to like go
completely direct about this but I would
tell you this year more than ever
because they didn't have all that extra
time in between the regular college
football season
the couple of all-star games you know
and and you know and now today you're
gonna see bigger you know bigger schools
that have you know tape you know what's
great for small school kids is they go
to these all-star games or to come in
and work out for team and you can do the
eye test at some level you can see it
and a lot of them when you know the tape
is so important aka the highlights for
everybody's watching there's no football
the problem is if you played a very
small school and most of your
competition including your teammates you
know some of these kids start growing
and becoming men in college and so in
high school they weren't good enough to
go to Oklahoma or USC or things that
make sure but like Jerry Rice the
all-time best receiver went to a tiny
school like we could sit here forever
and name them all
wink abet one of the greatest Jets of
all time with the Hofstra
like let you know those kind of players
they get to you don't know how good they
are because they're playing with such
inferior competition by their junior or
senior year so all this process helps
you quantify them yeah but I also think
so it comes out of Scouts
it's who had Scouts go into these small
schools yeah which Scout has leveraged
with the GM
to have the conviction to be able to I
would argue that today and tomorrow are
gonna be interesting and fine but still
we'll be in a pocket Saturday is gonna
be wild you start talking about you know
where it's really gonna be made as round
four through seven I'm really excited
about that a lot of the banner sports
kids are gonna go in that pocket
and I think that there's a lot a lot of
you know I I love our GM for the first
time in a long time for the Jets so I'm
actually very optimistic but I think
it's I think the teams are gonna shine
here are the ones who have the best
Scouts
you know WrestleMania kind of lost its
you know because there's no fans there
so do you think because Jerry can't be
there to be booed and hear all the booze
from the fans if he takes that pic
that's smart not you know sexy yeah yeah
I mean look I used to be the face in the
Jets pit years so so I idea I think
something will be lost I mean look we
need to get prepared for sports without
fans action games being played which i
think is then gonna make us really
appreciate the fans when it all comes
back yeah awesome bro thanks for being
on big fan a long time good luck with
everything
take care you too bro yeah I'm excited
for the draft tonight I think a lot of
people would be watching its me a lot of
fun let's keep it going
yo bro what's good bro are you doing
good to see you what's your name
baroque baroque real pleasure pleasures
mine actually we've met once before I
think it was a January 17 through Elliot
my boy came to your office we didn't
call brother I remember now I remember
it's good to see bruh good to see you
too man I have a quick question for you
today because it's something I've been
doing pretty actively since the last
three months on Instagram specifically I
see you've been talking about the whole
IDM stuff the strategy just get out
there and put yourself out there to
connect with people and you're like an
OG when it comes to preaching going out
there and everybody knows that I've been
commenting literally on every [ __ ]
meme page literally every time I mean
page post I have my post notifications
on and I'm on it the thing but but
without spamming like something
relatable whether it's like good job I
don't know if you saw but like I've been
hitting your your comment section
recently and even Alec this iman is like
oh [ __ ] the CEO of comedy mr. Graham's
here because that's why I like
self-proclaimed myself to make it fun so
I've been attacking it
certifications on four bunch two big
main pages and not being growing a lot
and seeing a lot of results I wouldn't
know what do you think about a strategy
strategy like that advice if welcome to
spot you made the most important part
you're not posting the same old thing
there's somebody I'm about to ban on my
page I never ban but he posts
I'll follow everybody who follows me
right now every time of my posts I was
even okay with that but then I looked at
he's not doing that so he's a con artist
you know as long as you're not just
posting the same old thing and you're
actually posting something that is
relevant to the post yeah I think that I
think you're just working very hard and
in the trenches similar to what I did
with Twitter in 2007 211 which is for 11
hours a day let there be no confusion of
how Gary B was created it was created
eleven hours a day on Twitter in 2007 of
me replying to every person I mentioned
anything about wine and me replying to
every person and I mean all of them
100% of them of anybody who applied to
me exactly no I took a right now and
I've no shame saying it because I'm
building my brand my brand I'm granting
it and that's what I want people to know
like like it takes time you know it
takes [ __ ] like a lot of dedication to
just like get there and I just want your
take on that's because a lot of people
look up to you as like the reference and
you know you serve a lot of people
saying oh it's spam or you do this you
do that amount of heat which I will
never let bother me but I feel like this
eight stops other people from doing it
it's it's it comes down to bringing
value if you're working hard for 15
hours a day and you're leaving comments
on you know people's meme accounts that
brings value you win its intent if
you're doing it because you know it's a
good growth tool and you're just
controlled copying and pasting or you're
half-assing the value bring because
you're trying to get to every mean page
you'll get exposed and regardless of
what me even though I what I sit where I
sit say it's in the nuances of the
intent it's like the gentleman two days
ago
I referenced it yes sir I'm gonna
reference again I love that dude the guy
the 55 year old dude we had a good talk
but like I knew when he was going
towards the end that I'm gonna give you
a couple of things I'm gonna ask for
something the things he gave me we're
not things of giving and the thing he
asked me for was the biggest cosign for
his podcast I'm not I noticed some
people said oh you don't like him no I
like him
fine if I didn't like him I would have
said no yeah but but but it's just in
tenth brother it's just [ __ ] intent
and I think you've got the right
strategy
I very much about understand why people
think it's spam because I see people
doing it to me yeah but there is a good
way to do it and a bad way to do it and
I think the good way to do it is to
really look at it and actually bring
value now that looks to me like hard
work if you're just posting the same
thing over and over or a half-assed post
so you can get to 5,000 of it it does
start bleeding a little bit into a
growth hacking not bringing value and
the universe knows even if I don't ban
the person that person will never have a
relationship with me because I know you
know what I mean and so yeah I'd rather
win with the 1% then trick the 99% and I
think if you keep that in mind for who
as well that that will be a good yeah
something funny something witty like you
don't really have to be out there and I
like I like the whole commenting thing
versus the IMing because it pushes you
to be out there to more people as well I
absolutely I've never I don't think I've
ever publicly talked about the tactic
but I've naturally privately talked
about the tactic yeah my good my concern
is that 99% of people just do the same
thing everywhere or a half-assed thing
it takes an incredible amount of time
you know something you know I like
anybody else likes to exaggerate here
and there I'm serious 11 hours day I
used to go to sleep up to 3:00 in the
morning that wasn't euro where I used to
go to wine library 10 a.m. 11 a.m. cuz I
was like dead I would go to sleep at
4:00 you know like it was it was a real
it was the real thing for me it was an
only Twitter
it was email I would reply it to every
email usually within the 24 hours so I
put in the work for my foundation and I
think you can do the same I would uh I
would really probably add 20 to 50%
effort to the individual comments which
will lead to you either having to work 2
to 5 hours more day or get to 20 to 30%
less mean pages but I think you can get
a lot more value if you add that layer
for it I totally agree with you and I'm
really happy you said that because
coming from you I feel like it's gonna
have a much bigger impact in the
committee as a whole but I would say
this and I appreciate where you're going
and you're flattering me me giving that
cosign in whatever way you take that I
still think if you know in your heart
you're doing it the right way it doesn't
matter what the other influencer
for other big people or you know what I
mean do it I promise you if you had more
depth to your comments you would even
get less pushback regardless of what you
know what I mean
a hundred percent a hundred percent and
it's always like that either you go the
funny route because yeah you can be a
comedian and make people laugh or you go
to more serious route and you be
relatable and you're trying to help
people if it's just a spam I think
you're just hurting the oak ecosystem
because 2bh comments is each comments
section is its own ecosystem living and
breathing I agree my brother talk to you
soon thank you bro see you got it
ot I want to go a lot left tackle swole
at number 11 I'd like to just trade back
I would love for the Jets the trade back
love Arnold what's good hey what's good
man I just want to say I looked up to
you like my entire teen years like you
really formed a lot of what I did so I
just want to thank you for that much I
appreciate that bro all right so I guess
my question is you know I recently moved
out I just turned 18 March 5th you know
really and I moved in with some friends
and I really did struggle a lot in high
school with the whole thing that I was
always good at music and I never really
I guess my parents perceived it as a
passion but I did more out of I was
always the best at it you know I played
at Carnegie Hall like 14 15 really then
yeah and then I like played the state
band every year played the state jazz
band and like I was always great at it
but you know I'd always read like
entrepreneurial books and I was always
good at that too so you know one day
when it was time to go into college
which was a whole nother issue you know
I wasn't even sure I wanted to go and it
was kind of out of just my parents
thought that was the way for me so I did
it and thankfully I had scholarship so I
didn't get into debt
but I went in as a long age just spur I
don't even know why and of course that
do my parents for a complete just as a
what brother as a law major oh ma major
I'm sorry you had my parents in for just
like a complete what happened what did
they want you to go in as a music major
okay and and you know I even realized
okay this probably isn't what I wanted
to do but it got me closer to you I did
wanted to do because I knew what I
didn't and I was moving towards what I
did I love it so what's the punchline so
I guess I want to get in the real estate
you know I want to get my real estate
license and yes yeah
well because a I like to sell like I'm
just I'm good with people and I like to
sell and I yesterday I also created an
Instagram page where I basically wanted
to create like a whole journey and a
whole community of people on a journey
to like with flipping things and
creating you know businesses and just to
document everything like you're just
attracted to the entrepreneur life the
game yeah okay
like I want to document all the little
losses that people tend to not do they
tend like glamorize you know well I made
a hundred a day what do I do but they
don't document all the losses they've
had so I wanted to create a community
that like expands and grows and goes
past that and I like it I wrote that so
the whole idea was like taking a a bank
account unquote from $0 and documenting
every process until it gets to a hundred
grand and what do you want to do after
that what's the plan yeah like I created
it as a I guess Instagram TV series and
that and probably during that I want to
create you know little talks with all my
followers like questions
what I think on certain topics you know
I want to get into life stuff as well as
personal finance and just help bring
people a lot okay so what's the question
how do I go about like with my parents
because it's not gonna bode well with
them and if I like go on and tell them I
don't think college is for me you need
to think about it two ways one are you
willing to have a tougher relationship
with your parents for the next two to
five years not as good as it could be
but still you know I don't know how your
parents would react are they gonna
disown you or is it just gonna be
disappointing or is it just gonna be
tension in the air but then have an
entire life of you not resenting them
which could lead to such a better
relationship for the rest of life or or
are you gonna listen to them and appease
them and forever resent them not super
complicated yeah I just I value because
I've always been kind of a hard-headed
kid and at times it has burned me but it
has also led to like some of the
greatest it hasn't it hasn't burnt you
you might have not been successful but
that doesn't mean you got burnt
it means you learned and you did what
you wanted that's actually called
winning yeah what you need to do is not
talk a big game and tell everybody that
you're gonna [ __ ] crush it and so
that you've got pie in her face but even
that's cool I like that too I even like
pie in my face so I don't think you
haven't burnt you just weren't
successful but you needed to do it
because you had conviction and just cuz
it didn't make a million dollars it
didn't work or it didn't happen
that's not burnt bro that's learning you
were [ __ ] burnt you [ __ ] learned
yeah you're [ __ ] eighteen you're
supposed to learn at 14 15 16 17 18 19
20 21 22 23 24 25 26 27 28 29 30 31 earn
yeah
losing is good you just told me he
wanted his document all the losses
losing is [ __ ] good yeah I know you
just you know your parents might have
thought you got burned your friends
might've thought you got burned that's
completely based on how much [ __ ]
privado and how much machismo you put
out into the world that this thing was
gonna be something yeah I like to say
things are gonna be something and then
when her or not I'm like yeah it wasn't
something I was wrong but I did this
other stuff other people like to stay
super quiet and then when it's huge like
see that's also good you know doesn't
matter it's still the same [ __ ] game
yeah how do you deal with your parents
with radical candor mom dad I love you
more than breathing you've done
everything for me I respect you the most
comma i 100% Know Who I am as a human
being you do not know me better than I
know myself I know myself better than
you know me you know you know I am gonna
do this you're gonna be disappointed but
if I do what you want me to do I'm gonna
do it and then for the rest of my life
I'm gonna actually subconsciously resent
and dislike you and we will never have a
great relationship this way you'll be
mad at me for the next couple years but
when I make it and I'm happy then you're
gonna respect me that's the conversation
you have and when your mom cries or dad
says you're a [ __ ] idiot or whatever
happens you [ __ ] to take that punch
like a man and you [ __ ] move on with
your life and then go [ __ ] prove it
you're right or you don't you know like
you know what I mean this is a binary
game how do you deal with it either up
front or not at all yeah cuz half
pregnant [ __ ] sucks
it does and that's kind of been like the
position I've been in where I kind of do
what I want to do and I always put my
happiness first you can't be selfless
without being selfish yeah what were you
gonna say
I've I've always 100% prioritized my own
happiness and I listen to you and I
listen to so many other people because I
know that's who I want to be and I guess
I just also at the same time haven't
been fully honest with my goals and who
I want to be that's fair with my and I
think I owe them that you do have to say
I think my happiness correct and also
you can't take anything from them yeah
zero yeah zero dunks that's no good for
you
zero dollars if you're gonna live on
your own two feet live on your own two
feet
I've got unlimited 22 year olds trying
to act like tough guys and gals but they
still want mommy and daddy to pay their
rent while they do it
yeah that's what that's why I took up
just any job because I know what you say
about [ __ ] jobs but I'm willing to do it
in fact job bud bro I respect you I
respect you heavy I'm listening to you
and you talk about me influencing you
and I'm like sitting here which I got
chills because I'm like this [ __ ] is
you know he was young when he started
listening to me it got into his head
look what he's doing he's [ __ ] moved
out with his buddies he's taking a [ __ ]
job he's standing on his own two feet
now we're gonna do the next part he's
gonna have that conversation it's all
gonna work I believe that man I believe
it iced generally see it in the world I
observe that's what I do like I'm proud
of you bro ninety percent of you man
ninety-eight percent of you bro don't
move out don't take a [ __ ] job they want
their [ __ ] cake and eat it too
so I'm gonna be your tough guy and I'm
gonna do this I mean while they want
mommy to paper to her mommy peas for
your uber you go to college if she wants
you to daddy pays for your [ __ ]
Equinox in your apartment you go take
law school if they want you to do their
[ __ ] painting it was such a big [ __ ]
into I apologize I'm talking through the
crowd you're such a big [ __ ] tough
guy your son [ __ ] amazing
you're so [ __ ] convicted go [ __ ]
eat dirt it was a scary thing you know
deciding to move out because I knew the
standard of living loss I'd take but I
knew that like in the long run that's
what I needed to do and that's the only
we're set be happy for yourself bro your
parents are gonna respect you I'm gonna
be disappointed cuz they had an ideology
but I'm telling you right now I promise
you you ping me when you're 26 and your
parents look you in the eye and tell you
how much they respect you after you go
this way I will believe you
I appreciate you bro I love you more
you too let's [ __ ] go let's go let's
[ __ ] go
hey Gary hunter he got me with this this
is a good episode we going is that a
Fitzpatrick no it's the Sam darlin let's
go thank God I was scared
hey so you kind of answered this a
little bit before um who are some of the
top people you want to see the Jets take
at number 11 I mean I know you've said
trading back potentially if they do try
back like who would you want to see them
pick I want them to take the Louisville
tackle back then that's who I wanted 11
I think it's the most upside I think he
be a perennial Pro Bowler I like him
better than then t what TW I like I like
him better than the Bama kid I like him
the best I think he's the most I also
think he might be the most risky but I
just have a feeling and I've done my
homework so I want them to take Becton
that's deadly uh you know if we don't
take offense at tackle if they're all
like off the board then definitely
training back is a good option yeah if
they're all off the board you know
Thomas TW like all these guys then then
I really want to trade back I really
don't want to take a receiver at 11 in
what I personally think is the best
receiving class since 2014 and and has
the potential to be the best one ever
there's gonna be a fourth round receiver
that I'm gonna be yelling at the TV
hoping Joe Douglas takes yeah there's
definitely um you know there's the
Arizona State guy what's his name
Brandon aaic I think it's loaded I'm
telling you it's loaded yeah it's loaded
how do you think it's gonna work online
do you think it's gonna be a disaster
tonight with the I'm not I've no
knowledge first of all so I know yeah I
don't know it sounded like on Tuesday
they were practicing it and it was a
disaster which makes me hope that
they've done a lot of things since yeah
you know but the ratings are gonna be
uncomfortable
I can't wait what's your number one
person that you want to take
definitely offensive line I was kind of
holding yeah which one do you like wills
or works yeah you know like it's a load
listen I think Boston Jackson from us
sees a good left tackle I think there's
some real guys the TCU kid there's I
actually think I mean I would be go I'll
go bananas if they trade down to like
the two Viking picks or or one in the
two you know like a one next year like
I'm a big fan of this draft and I would
I would trade down because I think they
can get a real tackle later in the first
round and and then just load the [ __ ] up
we have a lot of holes bro hunter like
if you really look at the team we got a
lot of holes yeah I think we got a
quarterback and and and but we have a
lot of holes
we really do if we're being honest with
ourselves we got it yeah so we need to
load up we need up we need one of those
iconic you know we need that you know
Revis David Harris combo that
D'Brickashaw up mango thing we need that
Brad Smith Leon Washington Jericho
Khatri fourth fifth round pick type
stuff you know Kerry Rhodes we need to
we need to hit here yeah definitely um
you know any help for Sam Donald at this
point we'll definitely take that because
his compared to last season his data
when he has a clean pocket is off the
charts yeah it's crazy
definitely alright brother take care
yourself YouTube good stuff excited to
flip him with that Fitzpatrick sure is
the bangle wheel exciting episode really
good day hope everybody's super well oh
by the way wine text today $125 Pinot
Noir for 45 bucks just giving you the
preview super pumped about that let me
know if you signed up in the comments I
want to say hey all right let's keep it
going
oh my god
[ __ ] off yep I won't Gary button I will
if you want it hey Tasha thank you so
much I appreciate you everyone
appreciates you right now watching this
I'm losing my mind
thank you to [ __ ] I'm just gonna get
right into the question very surface
level
if you want context I can give you all
the contacts thank you as someone who is
gratefully still employed during this
crazy [ __ ] but genuinely hates their job
like what do i what do i do do I just
ride this [ __ ] out while it's safe and
from I get to fire yeah
do you have savings a bit I mean I'd
rather not touch that to be honest I'd
rather you not touch it either my my I
don't really know what I want to do next
like I have I've had a lot of side
hustles I've dabbled in a lot of [ __ ]
but I'm just like if I was to quit I
don't know what the [ __ ] I would do I
love you listen I think that you
probably shouldn't because ya know you
know I usually like my preference when
people my first book crush it what I
really wrote in there was hey use down
time to build up something save money
and then you can wean off your job you
hate into something you love if you're
at a place where you don't even know
what you want to do yet you're kind of
far from that and especially to your
point I think it was another 4.2 million
Americans today declared Ron employment
in the last week to your point this is
we're gonna need to go into the
gratitude of being grateful for jobs we
hate right now because the alternative
sucks so what I would do if I were you
Tasha right now is really go ham on
crying [ __ ] like really as much as you
can't watching videos doing stuff you
know yeah I was old for tick-tock I was
like you know what I'm bored I'm doing
it you know I don't have [ __ ] on
tick-tock but it's still really fun and
I'm trying to explore but it there's
another level of nuance if I can offer
this situation Co my company they did
pay cuts across the board which is rough
but they did some layoffs in furlough I
have a colleague who was furloughed we
have essentially the same job and I'm
struggling with the guilt of keeping it
someone else from a job when I know I
don't like it yeah yeah I'm like [ __ ]
like should I just like surrender that
to someone else who maybe really does
need it and I can like make it through
so I love you I love you for that
humanity you know look to me in that
scenario there is no right answer
there's only the answer that you know
for
self I think it's extremely noble and
quite altruistic of you to like have
those feelings it's [ __ ] me up though
like that like support man it becomes a
game of how [ __ ] up are you if you
can't breathe and sleep for real and
you're not just and you're not just
trying to like convince yourself that
you're a great person then you do it if
it's a little bit of a caricature of
yourself and you're like in your own
little like altruistic woke world then
then you need to be thoughtful and say
I'm kind of almost doing this to appease
a narrative that I want about my own
self you have to go extra deep you see
where I'm going if I go super extra deep
because look I do think that like today
you can but god forbid we don't know the
world we're living in going forward and
you may need it one day you may need it
in a real way somebody the person you
love the most in your life may need it
and then all of a sudden you have a
regret that when you have the
opportunity you know as much as you love
your co-workers or homie you know
tomorrow a top five loved one might have
a real situation you may need those
dollars so there is a level of
practicality that you have to layer on
top of your humanity
sure yeah the thing I came she was like
contentment versus resentment like I'm
very grateful for the situation I have
even though I don't like it but I'm
trying not to [ __ ] myself up too bad
doing things I don't really like but
practical is what I need
practicality right now matters and but
but the most practical thing is for you
to start trying to do things I'm
tick-tock LinkedIn Facebook Instagram
and talk about things or learn things
that may become the thing you want to do
yeah like I started at YouTube I always
want to do that I was [ __ ] scared
shitless two years ago I started making
[ __ ] and like I'm really loving
learning how to edit videos it takes me
12 hours but yeah I'm one I'm one day on
Monday in fact and one day it's gonna
take you 42 minutes and one day you may
do that at vaynermedia you know what I
mean okay you know what I mean though
like yeah work on [ __ ] do [ __ ] learn
[ __ ] do [ __ ] learn [ __ ] you should
anybody who doesn't love their job right
now who's lucky to have one should be
spending every time at home downtime not
watching the news not watching me not
watching Netflix they should be learning
[ __ ] and doing [ __ ] because we're gonna
come out of this and it's gonna be a
whole new world and let me promise you
it's gonna be a world of winner
and losing this world we're gonna come
into is gonna be a game of winning and
losing and what I mean by that is
there's gonna be so much opportunity and
if you know what you want to do you
might be able to really get it
awesome awesome take care what bless
your heart Gary thank you hey Dustin are
you typing somebody's typing audio work
anyway
no it's some it's some of these people's
like phone devices for some reason the
audio just keeps any that's why I'm
muting them when you're talking so what
cool somebody was yeah
hey Gary what's up hey Dominic how are
you doing well man have our sauce really
well good pace about it question for you
so it recently got laid off my job about
a month to kill with everything going on
and for a couple years I've been really
wanting to start my own speaking
business and I think this is kind of
giving me a shove in that direction
problem is though and and with the post
speaking though like I'm not looking to
sell merchandise I'm not looking to sell
massive classes my main goals I just
want to be a keynote speaker and like
make sure my personal story yeah like
you problem is every time I talk to
someone they're like that's great man
you have a really interest interesting
story but what else you're gonna talk
about other than your story because
usually people keynote speakers they've
done something really no big in their
life they've overcome adversity and they
went on to be you know went being or
started a multi-million dollar business
know and I feel like I have a pretty
unique story and that's you know I
survived cancer when I was six months
old had a liver transplant when I was 13
lost my dad to cancer when I was 17 and
then lost my mom to cancer when I was 24
and then I just got laid off my job so I
understand that everyone goes through
adversity and stuff and I have to but I
guess my main questions how do I
discover you know what sets me apart to
allow me to be that keynote speaker to
draw audiences and stay hey
here this guy's story and what he has to
say um I think you put out the stories
for free on video over and over in
different variations and then you let
the demand come to you that's what I did
I didn't set out to be a public speaker
I made videos and then people started
emailing me and be like would you like
to take what you do on video to the
stage and then I said I don't know maybe
and I tried it and it was something I
was naturally gifted at then away a wet
I think you know you have the internet
so you should start doing live screams
and putting out videos and become the
honey and let the bees come to you
instead of begging the bees right and I
guess with that you know I took your
advice I've been listening to you lately
and I made it a talk account and I want
to be more active on social media but I
just feel really weird and awkward on
camera so I'm just talking to myself and
I don't know let me promise you this if
you feel weird on camera wait till
you're on stage in front of 500 people
right and I've done speaking before and
I'm comfortable now I feel completely
awesome so look I think I think you
don't have to do tic TOCs you could do
what you're doing right now with me
straight to video camera that's what I
did there's some old videos on viddler
calm well I think I called him Gary b-36
120s I would rant for twenty six you
know two minutes and they became the
foundation of me doing content not named
Wine Library TV you know I you know look
if you're unable to make content that
gives you leverage to get speaking gigs
then then you're gonna have to literally
just email conferences when we get back
to that world and say I'd like to be an
opening speaker for free
you got a speak for free it's like open
mics for coming before you do in Madison
Square Garden
that's Kevin Hart you're doing [ __ ]
shows for you know for eight people in a
club for zero dollars you need to do the
same thing right yeah and like I said
it's I just don't want to always put out
like so serious or somber you know
stories about my life belt om cancer and
I had this I lost my parents now I want
to bring upbeat you know inspiring
stories but at the same time as
I feel like I have trouble with that
when I'm trying to do it to a camera
one-on-one of myself maybe you need
somebody else maybe maybe do an
interview show you know maybe you get
six people to come in and you do it with
six people on a zoom and you record that
well I guess with that how do you feel
about podcasts it because that's
something I've been really rolling
around in my mind yeah I think I think
you're rolling too many things in your
mind like you want to be more active in
social media you want to you've been
rolling into mine on podcast I think
Dominic this is the great time to just
do right like I know my answer is always
yes Dustin I need a t-shirt for the show
I need I need a t-shirt dust and get the
team to make it the answer is always yes
got a desk yep burning it down thank you
so dom the answer is always yes yeah
what am I gonna say no right and like I
said this is the best opportunity to do
it now and ever if you need this
affirmation for me here it is
cosign go got proud of it good luck cool
thanks man
all right everybody good [ __ ] show I
gotta get to my next meetings I hope
everybody's super well somebody just
sound just see the answers always yes
yep yes there's always [ __ ] yes and
Whitney knows that Franklin knows that
Victor knows that Natalie knows that
Tyrone he knows that Mei Ming bang
definitely knows that and I appreciate
all of you all in challenge going strong
I'd like for one of you to spend the
full year with me we'll be playing that
video in one minute and then I'm telling
you right now $125 Pinot Noir for 45
bucks my my dad would appreciate it when
tax calm please already yesterday did
some homework I was dead I thought I'd
been converting the majority of this
audience I was dead when I saw what
happened I can't believe how many of you
have in the past tweeted drinking wine
or into wine and watch the show and
don't and have not signed up and you're
not from Texas or Michigan or Utah
you're in the pocket York New Jersey
Pennsylvania it is time the white
exocomp and it is time for you and I to
spend the entire year together and
here's how you can do that for a ten
dollar raffle ticket I am giving away
the ultimate garyvee experience how
should I go okay over the last week or
so I've been a gem with my friend
Michael Rubin and helping out on this
all-in challenge that I am accepting
right now but all-in challenge calm
please go there we are challenging some
of the greatest artists entertainers
athletes in the world
to provide a ridiculous all-time
experience or one of their most iconic
items in their collection to help raise
money to help feed the hungry during
this ridiculous time and so now I have
to put up my auction so my auction
the ultimate garyvee experience here we
go I'm gonna go off the top of the head
it didn't go on all-in challenge calm to
go bid on this I am giving away okay you
get to in the course of the year you
will go garage sailing with me and film
trash talk also you can get a workout
with me and Mike pecan tea so I know a
lot of you pay attention to that part of
my world also we're gonna go to Wine
Library and do a $25,000 shopping spree
that's right I'm gonna pay my dad well
I'm gonna donate we're gonna pay my dad
25,000 so $25,000 shopping spree at Wine
Library I will walk through the whole
store with you tell you the war stories
and you'll buy a bunch of wine beer
liquor whatever you want food we are
going to go to a Jets game together
you're gonna tailgate with me I never do
this when I give away Jets tickets I
never let the person sit with me so you
will sit with me during the Jets game I
won't talk to you during the game I'm
completely focused but you'll get that
so the ultimate Jets experience tailgate
full game with me as well also I'm going
to give you one week play at Vayner
media so this is for you and a plus-one
by the way so the two tickets the will
be some plus ones we'll do some just me
and you depending on what is one full
week at vaynermedia getting consulting
and business advice from team Gary B and
me for the entire week hanging out in
the pit where the shows done you're
gonna be a guest of my podcast we're
gonna do
wine dinner for you and seven of your
friends at Hunt fish club in New York
City and I'm gonna fly you all paid plus
1 to 3 of my keynotes and we'll work on
those details the ultimate garyvee
experience I hope you bid on it I hope
you get involved I hope we raise a lot
of money to help people that need it all
so what's so fun about the Olin
challenge is you get to challenge people
to be in it I am gonna challenge all the
Boehner sports athletes I expect you in
there so that is number one number two
I'm gonna go with ooh you know what
Tim Berlin the super producer who's
completely lighting up Instagram Tim
Berlin the super producer I'm calling
you out and finally I got one the
Undertaker
one of the great wrestlers of all time
please join the challenge everybody go
to all in challenge comm please support
this the experiences are gonna be nuts
we've been working bleeding out of the
eyeballs for the last week putting this
all together you're gonna be blown away
what you're about to see on social media
hashtag all and challenge please check
it out and please go to your favorite
celebrities athletes and entertainers
and leave hashtag all and challenge to
get them involved the all and challenge
please take it